à reins les débats de la Cour d'Assise
des mineurs se sont achevés aujourd'hui
débat sur les meurtres de deux enfants
commis en 1986 pour lesquels Patrick
Dils est rejugé les partis civiles ont
plaidé mais ce que l'on retiendra
Valérie hermit c'est que l'accusé a eu
beaucoup de mal à s'expliquer sur ses
premiers
aveux c'est vrai que Patrick d clamant
son innocence depuis maintenant 14 ans
tout le monde s'attendait à ce qu'il
prenne la perche qui lui était tendue
pour s'expliquer sur ses aveux très
détaillés qu'il avait fait à l'époque de
la vie de tous les avocats y compris des
siens d'ailleurs Patrick DS n'aurait pas
franchement su trouver les mots pour
convaincre répétant à plusieurs reprises
je ne sais pas comment ni pourquoi j'ai
pu donner autant de détails alors que je
ne suis pas coupable alors est-ce que
c'est un tournant dans ce procès qui
s'achèvera
demain c'est très difficile de répondre
à cette question Claude parce que le
hclot qui interdit au journalistes
d'assister aux audiences nous empêche
définitivement d'évaluer l'impact des
différents témoignages ce qui est plus
que vraisemblable c'est que la
déposition de Patrick dills aura été
l'un des moments clés de ce procès mais
au même titre sûrement que que la
déposition de Francis Holm le tueur en
série a nié avoir tué les deux enfants
mais il a reconnu avoir été tout près du
lieu du crime n'arrivant pas à expliquer
ce qu'il avait pu faire ce jour-là pour
la défense Patrick Dils est évidemment
innocent Francis Holm forcément impliqué
la démonstration n'a pas du tout
convaincu les partis civiles
réquisitoire et pldoirie de la défense
demain avec un verdict très attendu tard
dans la soirée merci Valérie